to the land of the remembered I made it
and on the Day of the Dead no less where
where you're going to be a little
disoriented at first don't try to take
it all in okay well your hands are far
too delicate for real scrimshaw work and
happen to be a charter subscriber to
middling warlord weekly so I'd recognize
you like it was see and you
how are you
Bible gun front
you didn't get an interview with a
couple I have footage imman I have an
interview with a neighbor she curses but
you can cut that out how did you get
inside the house the door was open they
allowed you well I heard somebody yell
to come in and when nobody was inside I
left and the only shot of the couple is
through a window the police were
shutting it down I don't like it like
what the footage looks like he broke in
theres no close-up of the homeowners and
he's giving us their name off a piece of
private correspondence scuze me that's
junk mail well I have a problem with
that will knock out a killer package in
my job know your jobs writing the tweet
of the day and getting Deb to turn
sideways during the weather for test